gilles leclair on a vraiment le
sentiment que cette cohabitation
s'annonce plutôt en douceur entre le
président de la république et lionel
jospin
oui il n'y a pas de problème d'ailleurs
les contacts se sont bien déroulées
immédiatement je dirais dès dimanche
soir et dès lundi matin l'entourage de
lionel jospin et l'entourage de jacques
chirac se sont immédiatement été mis au
courant informés et ont communiqué il
n'y a pas eu de problèmes ni de blocage
pour la constitution de ce gouvernement
de la part de jacques chirac dit je vous
arrête à l'instant dominique de villepin
vient d'apparaître sur le perron de
l'élysée on les coûts les dames
messieurs
conformément aux articles 8 et 9 de la
constitution et sur la proposition du
premier ministre le président de la
république a nommé madame martine aubry
ministre de l'emploi et de la solidarité
madame elisabeth guigou garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice monsieur claude
allègre ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la recherche et de la
technologie
monsieur jean pierre chevènement
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur hubert
védrine ministre des affaires étrangères
monsieur dominique strauss kahn ministre
de l'économie des finances et de
l'industrie monsieur alain richard
ministre de la défense monsieur jean
claude gayssot ministre de l'équipement
des transports et du logement
madame catherine trautmann ministre de
la culture et de la communication porte
parole du gouvernement monsieur louis le
pensec ministre de l'agriculture et de
la pêche
madame dominique voynet ministre de
l'aménagement du territoire et de
l'environnement
monsieur daniel vaillant ministre des
relations avec le parlement
monsieur emile zuccarelli ministre de la
fonction publique de la réforme de
l'état et de la décentralisation
voilà marie george buffet ministre de la
jeunesse et des sports sont nommés
ministres délégués
monsieur pierre moscovici ministre
délégué auprès du ministre des affaires
étrangères chargé des affaires
européennes madame ségolène royal
ministre délégué auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la recherche et
de la technologie chargé de
l'enseignement scolaire sont nommées
secrétaires d'état monsieur jean jacques
queyranne secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur chargé de
l'outre-mer monsieur bernard kouchner
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'emploi et de la solidarité chargé de
la santé monsieur charles josselin
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
affaires étrangères chargé de la
coopération
monsieur louis besson secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'équipement des
transports et du logement chargé du
logement
monsieur jacques danjou secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
des finances et de l'industrie chargé du
commerce extérieur
monsieur christian sautter secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
des finances et de l'industrie chargé du
budget madame marylise lebranchu
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie des finances et de
l'industrie chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises
du commerce et de l'artisanat monsieur
christian pierret secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie des
finances et de l'industrie chargé de
l'industrie
messieurs jean pierre masseret
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
la défense chargé des anciens
combattants mal à michelle demessine
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'équipement des transports et du
tourisme chargé du tourisme
les secrétaires d'état participeront au
conseil des ministres pour les affaires
relevant de leurs attributions
le conseil des ministres se réunira
demain à 10 heures au palais de l'elysée
avec à titre exceptionnel l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement
je vous remercie de votre attention
voilà c'était en direct dans le 19/20
l'annnonce du nouveau gouvernement du
premier gouvernement de lionel jospin